(host)
The year is 1924.
In a fog-draped gorge
near the foothills
of Mount St. Helens,
a group of gold prospectors
encounter a pack of ape men
near their remote cabin.
Fearing for their lives,
one of the group, Fred Beck,
fires his rifle at the beasts,
wounding one and scaring
them off for the moment.
Later that night,
the prospectors wake
to their cabin under attack.
Having returned under
cover of darkness,
the beasts hurled stones and
pounded on the walls for hours,
finally retreating
after sunrise.
The terrified prospectors
fled back to their Oregon town
and told their tale to
all who would hear it,
earning the remote spot
the name Ape Canyon
after the incident.
This was not the first
story of an encounter
with massive bipedal
hairy ape-like beasts
in North America.
Other stories go back
centuries across the continent,
but why does the legend
of this cryptid endure?
And what can Sasquatch teach us
about the anxieties we may have
about the wild world around
us and our place in it?
[triumphant music]
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka,
and this is "Monstrum."
Sasquatch is often described
as a large bipedal primate
or dark hair-covered
humanoid varying in height
from 6 to 15 feet with
broad muscular shoulders,
little or no neck, and
long ape-like arms.
Many sightings report
that the creature
appears more human than beast,
while others report glowing eyes
or a salivating
blood thirsty moth.
Our modern cultural
consciousness
positions this
mysterious creature
solidly in the 20th century,
placed there by the mass media
who often fail to report that
this monster origin stories
go back hundreds, if
not thousands of years,
and predate European
colonization of the new world.
The Sts'ailes people are
a First Nations community
located in the Fraser Valley
of British Columbia, Canada.
They tell of a shape-shifting
forest protector
known as Sasq'ets.
Sasquatch is an anglicized
version of Sasq'ets,
which translates
roughly to hairy man
in the Halkomelem language.
The Sts'ailes people
revere Sasq'ets
as a wild and elusive
guardian of the wilderness
who possesses
supernatural abilities
to protect and guide
those who respect
and honor their
natural environment.
In their culture, Sasq'ets
is the very embodiment
of the benevolent
spirit of the forest.
A little over 1,000
miles to the south,
at the Tulle River Indian
Reservation in California,
ancient rock paintings
or pictographs
depict a small group of
Sasquatch known as The Family.
It is believed to be one
of the earliest recorded
appearances of the monster.
The largest creature
in the pictograph
is thought to represent
a paternal figure
and is accompanied by
a mother and child.
Like Sasq'ets,
this hairy man figure
embodies traditional
human characteristics
like bipedal walking,
humanoid physiology,
and community building,
while also evoking the more
elusive wildness of nature.
In some legends,
they even had a hand
in humanity's creation.
But not all origin stories
from North American
indigenous folklore
depict Sasquatch
as a benevolent guardian.
Some feature the being as a
darker lurking malevolent force.
The Lummi people of
coastal Washington state
tell of massive bipedal
stalkers with furry white faces
who carry misbehaving
children off into the night.
Several Iroquoian and
Algonquian language peoples
share stories of
cannibalistic humanoid giants
known as stone giants,
stone men, or the Stoneclad.
Depending on the story,
these forest dwellers cover
themselves with stones
or rub sand on their bodies
to callous their skin.
In other traditions, they were
born with impervious skin,
while still others say
their fur is so matted,
it serves as pseudo-armor.
All of these conditions
make stone giants
resistant to human weapons.
Some of the most aggressive
versions of these monsters
have a particularly
grizzly penchant
for twisting the heads
off their human prey.
And legends of bipedal
beasts persist for centuries,
even after European colonialism
arrives in the Americas.
Sixteenth century Spanish
explorers and Mexican settlers
told of creatures called
Los Vigilantes Oscuros
or dark watchers,
tall shadowy beings
that appear on the peaks
of California's
Santa Lucia Mountains
during twilight, watching over
the land and its inhabitants.
The lore of the watchers
even made its way
into a 1938 short story by
John Steinbeck called "Flight,"
which describes the
monsters as menacing
but relatively harmless figures
who wouldn't bother
a visitor of the forest
if they stayed on the trail
and minded their own business.
In 1847, Irish Canadian
adventurer and artist Paul Kane
recounted stories told to
him by the Chinook people
about Skookums, wild men
who lived on the peaks
of Mount St. Helens
and engaged in cannibalism.
Kane offered cash rewards
for anyone who could
take him on a journey
to find the fabled Skookums.
But no such trek ever took place
and the stories remained legend.
And perhaps the most
infamous account
came from none other than former
president Teddy Roosevelt.
In his 1893 book,
"The Wilderness Hunter,"
Roosevelt details
a story told to him
by a grizzled old
mountain man named Bauman.
Bauman fearfully recounts
his personal experience
with a foul-smelling
bipedal creature
that ransacked
his trapping camp,
left large prints, stalked him,
and ultimately killed one of
his men by snapping his neck.
While neither Roosevelt nor
Bauman named the creature,
these descriptions have become
hallmarks of Sasquatch lore,
namely the foul smell
and oversized footprints.
This brings us to
the 20th century.
After the Ape Canyon
incident of 1924,
the next couple of decades
were relatively quiet
in terms of Sasquatch lore,
but advancements in media
starting in the mid 20th century
allowed for broader
dissemination
of mysterious monster sightings.
The 1948 introduction of
the Polaroid instant camera
alongside the development of
colored broadcast television
and the growing
presence of TV sets
in the American household
made it easier to feed a growing
appetite for tabloid tales.
Like when in 1958, a Bluff
Creek California logger
named Jerry Crew
discovered a series
of oversized
human-like footprints
near a bulldozer
on his job site.
The 16 inches long footprints
frightened and intrigued
Crew and his fellow loggers.
When he returned to town,
he brought his story
to Andrew Genzoli,
a reporter for the
Humboldt Times newspaper.
Genzoli interviewed the loggers
and published an article
about the event complete
with a photo of Crew
holding a cast of one
of the footprints.
It was in this article
that our monster earned
its new name, Bigfoot.
When given an English
language-based name
that was both simple
and evocative,
the monster became
a national sensation.
Under the new moniker,
older alleged sightings,
including the 1924
Ape Canyon incident,
became widely known and new
encounters were reported
via the emerging
mass media network
of American TV,
newspapers, and radio.
Less than 10 years
later in 1967,
another new technology,
home movie cameras,
gave rise to the
most famous piece
of documented Bigfoot
lore that exists to date,
the one virtually everyone
has seen or seen spoofed,
the Patterson-Gimlin film.
Shot on October 20th, 1967,
in Bluff Creek, California
by two friends and
Bigfoot enthusiasts,
the film clip captures
what appears to be
a large bipedal creature
trudging along a wooded hillside
in broad daylight
for almost a minute.
To this day, it
remains the most iconic
and controversial
piece of evidence
of the existence of Sasquatch.
It doesn't take a
film forensics expert
to see that the
Patterson-Gimlin film
could easily be replicated
by any small group of people
with a camera and a bit
of costuming know-how.
While there have
been confessions
and recently even AI evidence
that the footage does not
depict a mysterious monster,
for many, it still
stands as evidence
of Bigfoot's existence.
Some other familiar sightings
have been much more
reliably debunked.
In 1982, a retired logger
in his 80s, Rant Mullens,
admitted to having tormented
a small group of gold
prospectors in Ape Canyon
when he was a young man.
He said that he and his uncle
had thrown stones at their
cabin from a rocky overlook
in a playful attempt
to scare them.
Then later, having heard
that the prospector's tale
about fearsome ape men
made national news,
Mullens claims to
have perpetrated
several other Sasquatch hoaxes
in the region in the
years that followed.
In 2002, the family
of Ray Wallace,
a deceased coworker of
our footprint-finding
logger friend Jerry Crew
revealed that they
had found a collection
of large carved wooden feet
stored in his basement,
which Wallace had
purportedly used
to make the infamous footprints
in Bluff Creek back in 1958,
meaning even the origins
of Bigfoot's name
was the result of
a well-perpetrated hoax.
And yet, despite all the
evidence against its existence,
Sasquatch remains firmly fixed
in our cultural
psyche to this day.
Why, and why does it seem
that the public perception
of the monster has
shifted over time,
from friendly to fearsome
and back to friendly again?
Many films portray Sasquatch
as a fearsome monster,
like "The Legend
of Boggy Creek,"
the much maligned
"Cry Wilderness,"
and the properly terrifying
2013 indie horror
"Willow Creek."
And the image of
Sasquatch as a terror
has inspired some
gripping novels as well,
like "Devolution" by Max Brooks
and "Roanoke Ridge"
by J.J. Dupuis.
But the version of Sasquatch
many are most
familiar with today
is much more benign
and friendly.
It's one that we see as
a mascot for sports teams
or as a spokesperson
for snack foods or beer
or a playful character
appearing in video games.
We might owe this return
to a somewhat softer
image of Sasquatch
to the 1987 film, "Harry
and the Hendersons,"
which imagined the monster
as a benevolent and lovable
creature of the woods
whose existence is threatened
by human encroachment.
This iteration of Sasquatch
coincides with growing
public concerns
about environmental
issues in the 1980s.
The film's protagonist
is a reluctant hunter
who falls in love
with a titular monster
after hitting him with
the family station wagon
on a weekend excursion.
He and his family fight against
malevolent outside forces
hunting the beast
and are the only ones
who recognize Bigfoot
as a precious and
vulnerable entity,
much like our
natural environment
and wilderness spaces
who need saving.
In a way, the lore of
Sasquatch has come full circle
as our modern perceptions
of the monster
are an embodiment of respect
for our mysterious
natural surroundings.
Much like the earliest
lore of Sasquatch
from the indigenous
cultures of North America.
Debunked sightings, hoaxes,
and an often cartoonish
representation in pop culture,
and yet the legend of Sasquatch
still has fervent believers.
Why is that?
Ecologist Robert Pyle
contends that, "There seems
to be a general human need
"to create folklore about
larger than life creatures
"with names usually translating
to something along the lines
of wild man or hairy man."
He writes that,
"These mythical creatures
"represent a symbolic link
"to the untamed wilderness
that surrounds us,
"a connection to our world
that modern society
has largely lost."
It also wasn't so long ago
that our ancestors were
evolved to walk upright.
Using folklore,
particularly monsters,
becomes a way to outsource
or displace our primal
fears of the unknown world,
our unknown past, and
our unknown future.
We are scared of these creatures
that are not human but act human
and look more like
us and our ancestors
than we may want to admit.
Perhaps it is no coincidence
that the ancient lore
of Sasquatch evolved
and endured right alongside
the last century and a half
of North American
industrialization
and modernization.
From our fears of the
unknown American frontier
to our modern anxieties
about humanity's effects
on our fragile environment.
Whether Sasquatch is
a malevolent monster
or a misunderstood beast just
trying to protect his realm,
one thing seems clear.
The lore is likely to be
around for a long time to come.
Reminding us to keep an eye
on the big footprints
that we leave behind
as we move through this world.
Before you go,
I want to talk about death.
No, not monstrous death,
but death-death.
Or rather, I want to tell you
about a new series on PBS
Voices called "Dead and Buried."
It's a show that explores
cultural perspectives
and taboos surrounding death
and invite you to reconsider
how you think about
the inevitable.
We've got a link down below.
Tell them "Monstrum" sent ya.
In the Halkomelem language.
Halkomelem.
Should we do that again?
I think we should just do
that again for posterity.
Halkomelem.